[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul AKA Christian stale with
the puns and this video we're breaking
down the brand new rumors that a
returning Batman will be appearing at
the end of The Flash Grace Randolph
dropped the scoop last night and it's
been trending worldwide so I thought I'd
bring you our thoughts on the entire
thing you could please smash the thumbs
up button first and make sure you
subscribe because we're doing a trailer
breakdown on the movie coming this
Monday by the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
news it's all connected it's a great
post to this last night on Twitter
hashtag DC hashtag DC Studios I hear
there's gonna be a former Batman who
Cameo is at the end of The Flash and
could potentially stick around as the
new permanent DCU Batman Damien's dad
Pattinson is still solo I know who it is
but it would be in cool to reveal the
whole thing now with this she included a
picture of three Batman and later said
that it was one of these three it spells
off the back of a video that she dropped
last week talking about specific things
that could be coming at the end of The
Flash
now let me tell you a little bit of
flash T I found out just found out that
in the flash they've stripped out James
Gunn has instructed them to strip out
all of the teases at the end of the
movie Henry cavill's been taken out gal
gadot's been taken out Sasha Kaye has
been taken out so that's why they're
going with a different Supergirl uh it's
just going to be an else you know Barry
just runs between the universe the
Multiverse and everything's gonna stay
in the movie I also heard that Michael
Keaton was taken out of the end as well
so they're all out it's just going to be
Ezra Miller comes back to some other
reality so Ezra Miller is truly The
Flash wild card that he is in the comics
and he can go wherever he wants but
they're not going to keep anything from
that movie at least in the main Universe
it's just been all the promises of that
ending have been stripped down
I heard that they are filming a special
Cameo with a character from a long time
ago in the DC world so I think that's
going to emphasize that Barry can go
wherever he wants but that's a that's a
really really big deal and I do believe
because of that Sasha Kanye is not the
Supergirl that they're discussing here
because there is a Supergirl movie that
they're making which we're going to talk
about anyway let's become the world's
greatest detective and go of Hawaii we
can pretty much say that the person that
they're going to bring across is bail
and firstly Val kelma has had a lot of
health issues and unfortunately the
guy's almost completely lost his voice
due to suffering from throat cancer this
was a big plot point in Top Gun Maverick
spoilers and they clearly had to work
around it in that what do you mean it
was a spot it was the biggest movie of
the year don't pretend like you didn't
go and see it five times mate I'm
furious with you they're lying now they
worked around it in that movie however I
can't see them doing that in the DCU
because the Brave and the Bold Batman
needs to be in the action and the
franchise is going to be heavily reliant
on him secondly is George Clooney and I
I actually thought he was alright as
Bruce Wayne but as Batman should have
been put on ice because Batman and Robin
was met with a cold reception cool party
hahaha
I don't think he would do it as he's
often joked about how Batman almost
ruined his career and how he almost
ruined Batman Clooney is also 61 years
old and I think he's way past the point
that you bring him into someone's dad
and make him Batman for the next 10
years or so now the most obvious and
probably most loved Batman is Christian
Bale I still think that the Dark Knight
trilogy is one of the most well-received
comic book movie trilogies of all time
and Bale is the one actor that carried
that sure it had major casts and
villains but Belle was at the Forefront
of this for every film man's also been
dipping his toe in comic book movies
recently due to his appearance in Thor
living Thunder the last said about that
movie the better but we did talk about
how there might have even been a tease
to bail in the original Flash trailer
listen closely
are you in at the time I said that
sounded like handsome as score and the
Batcave itself was clearly laid out more
like the one from The Dark Knight
trilogy as opposed to Keaton's it had
the waterfall and pit in the middle
which is what we typically see with him
over the Tim Burton version now I do
think this shot is definitely Keating
from behind but either way it's
interesting that they chose to show
these things now hearing this I am kind
of a bit
um if it's bail can you do it oh it's
like one of those I'd love to see him
back obviously but I think they probably
need to do something with a voice or
maybe even have Damien make a joke about
how stupid his dad sounds he's got the
kind of attitude where the character
could definitely drop something like
this and it would endear the new Robin
to audiences secondly I am a bit unsure
on whether they should with the
ending of The Dark Knight trilogy
outside of endgame I really don't think
that another comic book movie comes
close and giving its characters a send
off to that level and I remember crying
in the cinema when I watched it because
I'm a little bit I do like the ending of
no way home mind but Bell send off was
by far are the best and the perfect way
to close out the trilogy if he's back it
also makes you wonder what's happened to
Joseph Gordon-Levitt man probably got
killed backing his car out of the cave
because he was well out of his death
however this would also offer the
opportunity to Damien to take his name
Robin as a tribute and it might make
Bruce realize that he's the person for
the job Damien is also the son of Talia
al Ghul so he'd have to learn some extra
stuff about what happened after that
night in the Mansion either way this
news is really interesting and it would
definitely give not only the flash but
also the DCU a bit of Goodwill The Flash
movie's been marred with several
different controversies and we also have
the entire thing going on with the DCU
at the moment I think all of the firings
were the wrong way to start off and it
kind of got the plans off on the wrong
foot we lost so many actors that people
liked in such a short time and fire
James Gunner was trending all the time
on Twitter since that day I think
bringing Bale back could actually win
people back around and I'm one of those
people who's like well I want to see
what he does but I also I'd like Tony
Cavill if I'm being honest and not only
would this get people interested in
going to see The Flash but it would also
put the DCU on the right foot and get
people excited for the upcoming Batman
movie DC is clearly Expecting The Flash
to do big numbers as they're doing a
Super Bowl trailer for that when poor
Shazam 2 releases in a month's time I
actually think it's smart to get an
established Batman to be the main one in
the DCU and then we're seeing how this
already built up character interacts
with having a son however I think they
would have to change things slightly and
I did watch The Dark Knight Rises last
week just randomly out of the blue I
forgot how messed up Bruce was in that
with the limping stuff so I think they
might do something similar to what
they're doing with Wolverine in the
upcoming Deadpool film The Multiverse is
now open and thus these versions are
slightly removed from what we've seen
before but we know some of the character
beats that they've already been through
so maybe Talia wasn't dropped in the pit
in that movie she got raised by her
father in normal circumstances and her
and Bruce got it on and then had a kid
Selena have you seen Dina now because
Bruce settled down with Talia and then
they possibly parted ways leaving Bruce
as the Batman in the universe I
genuinely think getting bail back is one
of the smartest things that gun could
have done as it makes the flash a
must-see movie within the past I know a
lot of people have been like this
film it also gets the DCU up on the
right foot and at least gives us some
solid casting for the Trinity it also
means that the flash is gonna feature
Keaton Ben Affleck's Batman and
Christian bells and therefore you have
these three characters together you know
some of the most well-loved ones all in
the same film which I think would be a
good way to Market it it just gets the
DCU off on the right third and at least
gives us some solid casting for the
Trinity where Man of Steel first came
out it was of course produced by Nolan
and there were talks that they might try
and get bail in the universe before
Affleck was cast this has been debunked
but I definitely think that the earnest
feeling of Man of Steel was building off
the back of the Dark Knight trilogy and
it's clear that in DC there's always
been this thought of like get Christian
mail back I think bail may be be a
pretty good place to start again and it
just depends whether he'd do it with or
without Nolan now as always take these
kinds of reports with a pinch of salt
but I do trust Grace especially when it
comes to DC she said Henry Cavill was
out when it seemed like there was no way
that would happen and she's really
confident in this obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts are you more hyped
for this movie if it's true does this
make you more excited for the future of
the DCU comment below and let me know
and just to let you know we're running a
competition right now giving away
wakanda forever to three subscribers on
the 15th of February all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on drop a comment below
with your thoughts on the video we beat
the comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch make sure you check out one of our
videos linked on screen right now which
is going over a topic you love because I
chose best for viewer so YouTube's made
that decision that you love it by the
way thanks for sticking through the
video I've been Paul no promises that
it's a good video and I'll see you next
time take care peace